let's begin with this product rule
question that's what you told me before
some of you um don't label which is you
and v and to be honest that's okay
unless
it's not um as i walked around a few of
you particularly for question two you're
mixing up which one was you which one
was he that's a signal to you hey you
know what just just put the extra bit
and it will help you out okay
so what i'm going to do is having just
labeled them i reckon we should be able
to work out
our v u dash plus u v dash
without too much trouble and again as
you've seen because we're adding it's a
product the order doesn't matter so
we'll have to worry about that on the
next question
in this case v is log of x
like so by the way fun fact when you
have a look at um textbooks they will
sometimes just write down log x and this
is the log that they mean base e
unfortunately on your calculator that
exact same thing doesn't mean base e
what does it mean
base 10 and you can tell there's
actually a clue on your calculator above
this button
it will say if i'm not mistaken it will
say like 10 to the x so what it says and
that's your clue that's your reminder
that this is base 10. again it was
because of that scientific notation
scientific calculator so just note for
that when you're reading it it means
this when you're pressing it it means
that okay
there's v what's u dash in this case
it's just one so it doesn't change
anything but i like to write it for
completeness
we set u as being equal to x
and then the last piece is the one we
just proved what's v dash
one over x so it's gonna nicely simplify
out okay i'm just gonna get
log base e of x plus one
happy times
all right let's have a look at the next
one question was always a little bit
trickier but what we're differentiating
is
is it x minus one on log x
i can't even remember
yeah happy times so uh just like before
i'm going to set my u and my v
and even though i've literally done this
tens of thousands of times i still like
to write the quotient rule
just because i'm paranoid
about misremembering something or just
jumbling it in my brain okay it doesn't
doesn't take long i did it while i was
talking to you guys so it's a real time
saver if it helps you get things right
let's have a look what's v
just log base a of x
what is u dash
just like before it's one that's nice
here comes u it's x minus 1
and then my
v dash which we've already seen and
we're going to use again it's
1 over x
all divided by make sure you get the
right part it's all of this
squared and i would highly encourage you
if you haven't already pops in brackets
around there because if you don't it's
not clear at all what's being squared is
the x being squared or is the whole log
being squared and we want the whole
thing okay now in this case there's
actually not a huge amount that can be
simplified right when you have a look at
this you're like okay log
that's great and then over here you're
like
to try and get rid of these fractions if
i expand guess what happens you just get
another fraction so you're like
whatever right if you really wanted to
you could actually multiply through the
whole numerator by x which would mean
you would also multiply the denominator
by x and that would get rid of your
fractions right so if you wanted
this would be fine i'm going to go x
log x minus x plus 1
all over
x
log or squared does one of those look
obviously simpler than the other one to
you
i mean to me it's much of a muchness
right so i'm like i'm fine just leaving
there usually i don't like fractions on
fractions but i don't think this is a
clear advantage so i think you'd be
totally fine just leaving it there okay
all right now we're on the tail end of
these examples but four has a bit of a
um a twist in it so let's have a look at
three quickly it's log
x
and it's all
cubed okay now at this point it may help
you to do chain rule fully right because
we're pretty good at that if we do our
notation properly so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to call this as i have
with product and question rule i'm going
to call it u
okay
now having done that i then need to work
out
what this whole thing is y equals
u
cubed then this works lets me work out
my two different derivatives the things
that chain together does that remind
remember how that works d y on d u what
happens when something is cubed
it becomes
3
u squared
and in the same way i'm going to
differentiate this thing uh d u on dx
and that's the same familiar log x we've
been using this whole time right so it's
going to just be equal to
one over x
to get the full derivative d y on dx i
just need to chain these two together
this one
and this one okay so
here we go
d y on dx
equals
i'll write down
this one first and instead of u i'll
write it just the way it was before so
it was 3
log x squared
and then i'm multiplying by this
i could write times one over x right at
the end but i'm just going to go in one
hit because i can finish right there
does that make sense
okay very last one let's look at this
one together and i'm going to do it in
much the same style i'm going to
introduce a u and do that substitution
so the question is
for
y equals was it x squared minus one yeah
cool thank you
okay
so watch closely right pull the same
trick let's call this thing u
x squared minus 1. that's my u
so therefore y is going to be equal to
log base e of
well i'm not calling it this anymore i'm
calling it you so
write that and what this gives me is a
new
derivative d y on d u now i've changed
the letter but as we've discussed before
the letters are just labels so in fact
what i saw before
there we go
instead of one over x it's going to be
one over
u
okay there's one part of the chain
here comes the other part it's d u
on dx what's the derivative up here
2x very good you guys are getting really
really fluent at this i just need to
piece these two together and i've got a
derivative so let's have a look
d y on dx equals
i'm going to do this one first
2 x i could multiply this by 1 over u
but it's the same as dividing by
u and you guys know what u is we said it
right up there
x squared minus 1.
now this is actually such a neat little
form do you see it's just a fraction
where the top
is the derivative of the bottom can i
just say that one more time
what we've got in here is a fraction
where the top is the derivative of the
bottom so a shorthand for that that
you'll see a lot and you'll even if i'm
not mistaken see it on the reference
sheet it's f dash
on
f it's kind of like a really nice form
it's a very easy formula to remember so
this is what happens whenever
you differentiate
log of
whatever you want
stick anything in there right x squared
minus one put in any of those other
functions you want if you put it in
there you differentiate it you get f
dash on f which kind of rolls off the
tongue nicely okay